all right guys this is a movie reviewing
channels generally speaking I review
movies but it's not all I do sometimes
it is gonna bring you something that's
really cool sweet simple entertainment
that's 15 minutes long it's like hey
watch that because it's awesome as party
as I've seen the gripes in the comments
section of people who are like Jeremy
doesn't review indie films you only
reviews big budget things pretty sure
grand Budapest hotel itself had a bigger
budget than this short film the you
eat my dick people who say only review
big budget thing indie YouTube fan film
is pretty much the epitome of low-budget
so this camp right there is a short film
that hit the Internet today it's a
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers short film
and we've seen some really sweet short
films on YouTube lately the truth in
journalism short film that was
ultimately about venom that dirty
laundry one that had Thomas Jane as the
Punisher and it was about the Punisher I
saw this and I kind of I got that
feeling like I did when I saw Mortal
Kombat rebirth where I was like holy God
my childhood and I need to talk about
this right now such an interesting take
on the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers in
this short film it's within continuity
to a point is like all right we're going
our own direction but ultimately the
Power Rangers are grown up the Machine
Empire is ultimately one it's integrated
its technology with ours and now hood -
here we are as Kimberly played by Katee
Sackhoff she's in this interrogation
chair rocky is ultimately turned
turncoat Rocky's played by james van der
beek
it's Dawson and he's interrogating her
being like where's Tommy Oliver
otherwise known as the coolest Power
Ranger ever made certain he's the best
what I like about this this reminded me
of Power Rangers meets Watchmen even
rocky says in there he was like we were
children made to fight an intergalactic
war against an enemy that we'd never met
before so it's like gosh they would be
messed of wouldn't they especially Tommy
you know he like he was evil and then he
had power and then he lost it and had it
me lost it so now they all have PTSD and
when they're they're not Power Rangers
anymore summer dead summer mercenaries
Tommy Oliver's like off the grid he's
like the cool kind of bum he's a nomad
it's just the way it is you see this
nomad a guy used to be a Power Ranger
who's completely homeless if the garbage
bins it's like nah but you know you got
like you're a bum and I say bum I don't
know in 2015 I feel like there's a lot
of I used to be able to say that I
can't say anymore I really love this
I liked seeing where the Power
Rangers are now that they're all grown
up and they're not necessarily Power
Rangers anymore I would have liked to
have seen Jason David Frank come back as
Tommy but because you feel like are
they're all adults so why isn't Jason
David Frank back is Tommy doesn't he do
MMA fighting or something like that
maybe he was doing other stuff I promise
you
he was approached to do it this is
ultimately power rangers fanservice I
know a lot of times in movies with
movies or fanservice people are just ran
service it's not really
actually his advantage every when it's a
15-minute long movie and it's put on the
internet just for the sake of
entertainment it's allowed to be
fanservice and this is not your
childhood Power Rangers not like you can
sit down with your kid Timmy who's like
8 years old be like hey Timmy this is
what I used to watch when I was your age
no no no no there's like brain splatters
and there's a lot of blood it's really
violent this is a Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers fanservice fan film that's made
for Mighty Morphin Power Rangers fans
who were fans of Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers when it aired ultimately I see
this as the possibility of a Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers movie because I
always said yeah I might anymore from
Power Rangers movie that would be cool
if you saw I believe it was my Q&A video
and I said that Narrows like that could
be like x-men meets Pacific Rim that's
awesome but now I'm thinking like I kind
of want something like this where it's
an in continuity reboot or it's like oh
yeah the events of Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers happened and now they're older
and maybe some of them are not good
anymore maybe they went with the enemy
but I saw here was something that I had
never thought about before and that's
what I love most is like when someone
can make something I was like oh hey
here didn't think about that did you and
I'm like no I didn't my one hang-up is
at the very end it's kind of gonna be a
spoiler here if you haven't seen it go
watch it if you don't want it spoiled go
watch it right there's a link below to
watch this short film go watch it but
for the rest of you who did this is
spoilers now you've been warned at the
end Tommy's looking at Kimberly's like
who are you and she's like I'm
Kimberly's like no I held Kimberly she
died who are you and she's like don't
you remember me and her face is like
cracking away and she's like I created
you and she boom she turns into Reed and
she's like mechanics is us and he's like
Reed slash in the end I was like all
right radius costume first of all kind
of looks like something out of Halloween
workshop like something you would buy at
Target at the mall or something for some
odd reason it yeah it just kind of took
it down from this really gritty
realistic take on Power Rangers it's
still you know it's it's Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers not going to completely be
realistic but it was you know it's like
dark hat it's great then it was like
it's like cheesy again and it's kind of
some of that Rita makes it jay-z this
feel like the Rita execution wasn't as
good you could have had Katee Sackhoff
face just kind of crack a little bit and
out of implication she's like I created
you don't you know me and he could just
been like radar and you know that Rita
shape shifted in to look like Kimberly
and that's
you need to know that instead you have
this cheesy take on Rita I didn't like
it it's not two ways around it isn't
like but all in all this Power Rangers
short film or bootleggers the producer
calls it I loved it I was like it's like
my childhood met my older self and we
were like here is something that comes
together that we can both enjoy I'd love
to see more of these just like you have
Lord Zedd the Pope from you where's
Goldar is he alive does this show me
more guys I bring this to you because I
genuinely believe that you will enjoy it
I put a link below go check it out so
this Power Rangers short film have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more